I have always been fascinated with
fighting games they're flashing their
nuance they exude style they take
countless hours of practice to break
into and once you do your skill is on
display for everyone to see but I'm also
intrigued by the culture surrounding
them the moments in emerge from Evo
tournaments and the story behind games
such as Street Fighter 2 fighting games
have a devout community and a rich
history and I've always enjoyed
observing both from a distance but
that's just the thing
I've always been an observer and
outsider looking in I've dabbled in
countless fighting games and watch my
fair share of tournament highlights yet
I never found a game that reeled me in
encouraged me to practice ease me into
its mechanics in a way that I personally
found effective in many ways I was
waiting for something like injustice to
[Music]
when it comes to video games the word
accessibility has attracted a few
stigmas it's sometimes seen as a red
flag to devoted fans that a developer or
publisher may be more concerned with
sales than depth of design casting a
wider net to make a game many people
will like rather than a game a handful
of people will love I'm reminded of
Diablo 3 in 2012 when it released many
fans of the earlier games derided the
sequel to hear some tell it developer
Blizzard had gone too far in making the
franchise accessible dumbing down the
systems and mechanics so to speak to
draw more players into the action RPG I
happen to adore Diablo 3 but many fans
found it to be a shallow representation
of the series they were so fond of look
also at a more recent title created in
partnership between halo developer 343
industries and the RTS veterans at
Creative Assembly Halo Wars 2 has a bit
of an identity problem is it a simple
strategy game created for Halo fans or a
superficial halo game made for RTS
players I recently returned to it and
I'm still struck by how uncertain the
whole thing feels
I love halo and I love RTS games but in
trying to satisfy both camps as much as
possible 343 and creative assembly
really something that doesn't accomplish
either but now we have injustice to and
with it a shining example of
accessibility done right the old days
were fun but these days I'm all business
as someone who has started myriad
fighting games before ditching them
hours later injustice 2 began on a
familiar note I jumped into a tutorial
learn the basic light medium and heavy
attacks how to block enemy advances and
how to cow ball all of this together
then I learned things more specific to
the injustice series hero powers super
moves and the wager based class system
to name
try a little tenderness not while I'm in
beast mode and then as is usually the
case injustice 2 taught me more complex
mechanics and I could keep track of at
once
meter burns block escapes cross ups
delayed get ups move cancels it all
blended together and I remembered why I
was hesitant to begin the game in the
first place I didn't have the time to
learn all of these mechanics and with so
many other great games to catch up on I
was ready to give up but then the
tutorial ended I spent a few minutes
exploring the menus I scrolled through
the roster and in an effort to give it
one more chance I jumped into the game
story mode the opening cinematic was
fantastic the first few fights let me
sample several characters and the campy
plot drew me into the weird world of DC
Comics and if you know much about
injustice 2 by this point then you know
I gained loot throughout my early hours
new pieces of gear for different
characters whether it's a new bow for
the green arrow or a different chess
play for Aquaman they grant basic stat
changes for strength health and defense
and in some cases offer passive
abilities for use in various injustice 2
modes but they also change how these
iconic heroes look and I realize it on
the surface this is a simple thing to
enjoy seeing Superman and jagged
sinister armor or Batman wearing a red
suit but as time goes on these
characters morph the more you use them
and more importantly they can look
extremely different from one player to
the next this results in an empowering
sense of ownership the more you play one
character and learn their intricacies
the more likely you are to morph their
appearance your max level scarecrow
becomes not just a new aesthetic
variation but a source of pride
you have a high tolerance but everyone
has something to fear the introduction
of RPG progression into other genres is
nothing new at all Call of Duty for
introduced this to mainstream shooters
with its loadout system setting a
precedent for multiplayer games today
Assassin's Creed Brotherhood let you
further shave your protagonist and
upgrade fellow assassins as well and
more recently titanfall 2 made a similar
departure ditching the burn card system
of its predecessor for a more
personalized progression tree many games
use role-playing characteristics just
for the sake of added content or keeping
players hooked until the next DLC pack
drops but here in injustice 2 it's
encouraging me to learn as onra that I
had previously deemed in penetrating I
haven't even mentioned the multiverse a
single-player mode with rotating
challenges loot rewards alternate
reality battles and difficulty modifiers
that keep things fresh from day to day
it's here where I spend most of my time
because it crucially allows me to play
how I want to play I can remain at the
same a AI difficulty level earn new gear
and complete new challenges without
having to face AI or human opponents
that far exceed my skills it's here
where I can play injustice to in my own
pace now ten hours later I'm still
playing injustice 2 for the loot but I'm
also playing because I want to get
better I want to learn it's complex
systems how they overlap and how I can
use them to my advantage I want to
become an expert with three or four
characters watch them change alongside
my skills and maybe even delve into the
frame data available for each one time
will tell if I actually get that far
into it
[Music]
but all this is to say that injustice to
uses accessibility to do something
fantastic it ruins someone unfamiliar
with a genre let me have fun however I
wanted to and encourage me to go deeper
I'll say that again it encouraged me to
go deeper it did not force me it said
there is a lot more to this game than
you're seeing at the moment but you're
having fun and that's completely fine
accessibility has become a largely
negative term in recent years as fans to
cry developers for supposedly dumbing
down their favorite series but I don't
think accessibility has to be a bad
thing and the more people the video game
industry attracts the more diverse it
becomes and as diversity increases both
in the people making games and in us the
people playing them the higher the
chances are that will find great games
to play games are only going to keep
growing and I think it's important now
more than ever to figure out how to make
them accessible without sacrificing
quality or depth to convey complex
mechanics and systems to people who
aren't already well versed in them if it
weren't for injustice - I might not be
looking forward to fighting games in the
future and I wouldn't be encouraging you
to give them a try when they release but
here we are in my fascination with
fighting games has finally exceeded an
outsider's interest injustice - is a
complex game underneath but on the
surface I'm going to keep having fun
however I want to
you're getting shut down don't be so
sure
[Music]